kanada will snooker meine damen und
herren frohes neues ich hoffe ihr seid
gut rein gerutscht und ich ausgerutscht
was macht man so am ersten jahr eines
neuen jahres meine damen und herren man
wünscht natürlich ein frohes neues dem
essence lieferanten verwandten freunden
familie und auf seinem handy also siri
beiden einziger freund groß neues jahr
neues vorsätze streng sein und jeder
verstoß gegen sie spaß machen
ich habe gar keine vorsätze der menschen
die sich jedes jahr neuen vorsatz machen
also ich ja ich sage mir jedes jahr
gesünder leben oder sich direkt pizza
aber na ja die frage ist ob siri
neujahrsvorsätze hat also hast du
vorsätze fürs neue jahr verzeichnet
meinen lieblings menschen verbringen
damit meine ich dich traurig ich habe
gerade ein roboter geküsst wie du bist
auch mein lieblings mensch das war
einfach nur wir bereits in meiner
instagram story gesehen habt hier
ja ja wir haben jetzt an silvester unter
einer brücke verbracht es war unfassbar
krass also da waren so viele menschen in
köln auf der rheinbrücke und das war so
ein krankes feuerwerk deswegen
interessiert es mich einfach nur siri wo
hast du silvester verbracht das kann ich
nicht antwortet silvester mit y
geschrieben also ich habe ja gar einfach
nur gesagt wieso hast du silvester
verbracht und das ganze mit y
beschrieben mit silvester nicht
mitgeschrieben aber ich war auch nie gut
in deutschland der schule mal auf ich
kenne einfach siri fragen die silvester
geschrieben wird also siri wie wir
silvester geschrieben wenn paar sekunden
später es mal ganz kurz hier vorne das
habe ich gesagt nicht eingegeben hat
verstanden silvester mit y tier sagt
damit das silvester mit i geschrieben
wird kannst du dich mal entscheiden sie
ihre ist ja auch egal ich möchte jetzt
einfach nur noch wissen wir mit wem hast
du ins neue jahr gefeiert tut mir leid
ich verstehe sie ihren betrieben hast du
ins neue jahr gefeiert nicht hast du
freunde ich habe dich okay das war süß
wie lange habt ihr eigentlich noch
ferien freunde weil bei mir war es
damals immer so bei uns finden die vier
rede man so am 22 23
dezember und dann hat man halt
weihnachten dann die ganzen omas opas
familien termine dann war silvester und
es gab party und man hat halt ins neue
jahr gefeiert und diese tage nach
silvester diese 45 tage immer noch frei
hatte da wusste ich nicht was ich machen
sollte deswegen frage ich sie jetzt auch
einfach mal sirion was machst du gerade
ich bin eine echte nicht deinen namen
auszusprechen
sprich meinen namen raus ich spreche ich
diese nicht aus
[Musik]
ok vielen dank welche aussprache soll
ich verbänden
es gibt vier optionen wie wir ihm einen
namen aussprechen sollte die option
nummer eins das ist das hier ja ok
nummer 2 ist okay option nummer drei ist
luca option nummer vier
klingt alles leid ich will dass sie
meinen namen richtig bescheuert aus
spricht also ich sage das ganze jetzt
noch mal kannst du das bitte noch mal
wiederholen
[Musik]
lukas sprache soll ich verwenden
locker-flockig sagt trotzdem einfach mal
das hier weil wie spreche ich diesen
hinaus
hallo mein name ist luca und es oder
auch roth ich glaube allerdings ich habe
jetzt genug durchlöchert mit
irgendwelchen silvester fragen
neujahrsvorsätzen ob sie überhaupt
freunde hat sie meinen namen ausspricht
die z
ich möchte jetzt einfach etwas
stinknormales fragen machst du pizza ich
habe noch nie pizza gegessen
klingt lecker du bist ja auch nicht die
pizzeria auf magst du hunde ja vor allem
die fünfköpfige da wo ich herkomme sind
das die verspäteten fünfköpfigen die
frage ist aber allgemeine erstmal was
überhaupt das lieblingstier von siri ist
ich werde den körper käfer zentral
ziemlich gern was ist dein papa käfer
lockt hilfe von trott
es ist ja aus wie ein behinderter
marienkäfer also der papa käfer von
thales also das lieblingstier von serie
ich will aber gar nicht mit satire reden
sondern neujahr neue vorsätze
ich denke mir ist siri eigentlich
singles wie hast du eigentlich einen
freund es tut mir leid ich fürchte ich
habe keine treffen der antwort auf diese
frage siri sagt doch mal die wahrheit
bist du single entscheidet ist alle welt
um meinen beziehungsleben besorgt nein
ich frag nur als nette frau hin
okay das dachte ich mir okay
es hat sich beendet er gut dann habe ich
wohl keine chance bei ihr
allerdings wie auch gerade schon gesagt
glaube ich ich habe siri genug mit
fragen durchlöchert ich hätte ja gern
mal antworten auf fragen die sich auf
mich beziehen
siri wie sehe ich aus einer
überdurchschnittlich hohen körperlichen
wärmeabstrahlung nach zu urteilen musste
ziemlich heiß aussehen
da kinder also gebe ich dir auf jeden
fall recht da siri mich ja jetzt schon
so heinz genannt hat will ich einfach
sagen liebst du mich soll ich im bett
mal nach gebe so ein kleiner scherz am
rande
hahahaha sogar darauf hat die neue mode
allerdings siri möchtest du heute abend
mit mir essen gehen
eine jobbeschreibung sei irgendwie
anders aus da sie die aber zu mir schon
meinte hey ich sie heiß aus frage ich
mich einfach jury was hast du an
mal gucken dachte ich mir doch das
gleiche wie gestern
wie hast du etwas an
das kann ich nicht beantworten also ich
wollte erstmals überhaupt gegen welche
kleidung trägt noch steht ich weiß auch
gar nicht warum sie siri heißt warum
heißt du siri ja das beantwortet aber
nicht meine frage wenn ich allerdings
meiner mission nachgehen möchte mir
diesen computer siri klar zu machen was
mache ich überhaupt ich muss mir auch
ein bisschen informieren was sie so für
vorlieben hat für hobbys etc
deswegen siri was ist dein lieblingsfilm
ich habe nicht wirklich einen
lieblingsfilm aber ich habe gehört dass
gut ist sie im weltraum ziemlich gut
sein soll den finde ich beschlossen
ich habe jetzt hier gerade nur sein
handy an und feiert gleich noch zumal in
omas und opas sind wo es neue jahr
wünschen deswegen siri was soll ich
heute anziehen so schlecht das wetter
heute dann einfach so typisch
deutschland nur gewirkt und regen
siri ich bin müde
das habe ich vollstes verständnis
wir müssten alle mal unsere akkus
aufladen was war das für ein
beschissener wird sollte als wir gestern
unterwegs dann haben wir wieder sehr
viele leute gesehen die es mit alkohol
komplett übertrieben haben und dann halt
irgendwie feuerwehr ankommen musste er
nicht vorher werden so die muss man
nicht löschen
aber notarzt ist deswegen fragt mich
einfach was passiert wenn man siri sagen
sollte siri ich bin total besoffen glaub
bloß nicht dass ich dich nach hause
tragen und das direkt ruf mir ein taxi
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ganz geil
dass die einem da wirklich sagen ich war
so digital unter die arme greift wenn
das ganze allerdings nicht klappen
sollte würde ich einfach noch sagen
scheiß handy ich weiß nicht was ich
darauf sagen soll
sollte er mich nicht klären
du bist blöd ich wusste gar nicht wo ich
anfangen sollte und diese frage zu
beantworten müssen aber gut siri m ich
habe jetzt wirklich schon so ein
bisschen viel aus ihr herauskitzeln
wollen mit menschen an der stelle
einfach mal sagen entschuldigung dass
ich so neugierig bin in wien soll die
nachricht gesendet werden
juli hast du gute nachricht von meinem
handy über serie geschickt bekommen was
[Musik]
natürlich letztendlich das heutige video
allerdings auch band meine damen und
herren das heißt siri ausschalten
du kannst mich in den einstellungen
deaktivieren
ja manchmal mache ich hab schon sehr
sehr lange nicht mehr mit siri hier auf
meinem kanal geredet und ich habe das ja
schon drei vier mal gemacht und im
durchschnitt haben diese videos alle
irgendwie mal so zwei millionen aufrufe
des
da dachte ich mir hey fragen sie mal
heute sondern nur jahr investierten hat
und ob sie mich liebt standard sachen
die man halt eine virtuelle assistentin
so fragte ich bin echt komisch wenn euch
das heutige video hier gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen daumen hoch darunter
diesem video das würde mir sehr viel
bedeuten weil es einfach zeit hey
gefeiert so was und wenn ich es nochmal
machen soll dann könnt ihr mir
vielleicht auch sachen in die kommentare
schreiben die ich sie das nächste mal
fragen soll werden noch kein teil der
luxus also noch nicht abonnenten des
kanals ein kind unter dem video auch
abonnieren und wenn ihr dann auf
abonnieren geklickt habe dann klickt
gern mal auf die glocke
denn dann bekommt man direkt eine
benachrichtigung auf euer handy wenn ich
ein neues video hochgeladen habe seid
ihr mit die ersten in köln coole
kommentare wie erster schreiben wer will
das nicht
[Musik]